hello Luca congratulations I adore your
movie you're so kind thank you I mean it
um so first here I was listening to your
New York Film Festival q a where you
emphasize the value of not using a shot
list and how that kind of allows you to
get lost in the process and then find
the moment that way so it was making me
wonder is there any particular example
of you doing that on Bones and all that
you're especially proud of a scene where
you really had to get lost in order to
find what you needed but all the all the
scenes I would say it's not that I want
to get lost in the sense that I don't
know what I'm doing the actual opposite
I think it's about really getting to
summon your point of view only in the
only place that it needs to be and you
can only do that if you first and
foremost see the scene happening if you
actually
let the performance breathe when you do
once you do that then you kind of
experience that
you can then decide that what you saw
can only be seen from that perspective
of that perspective so in a way
it's all about
faith and trust in the beauty of
performance in that case to build on
that is there an example where you
trusted your Ensemble they did something
so out of left field that you never
could have imagined and then it made you
think like that's totally different than
what I initially pictured but that's
great and we have to go that route I
don't know if it was about being
completely different than what I
pictured because again after I thought
that I did my first feature film in 1998
and I had to put in my mind every image
I wanted and then I failed I decided
that I was not going to anticipate what
I wanted but actually open myself up to
what could happen
um having said that I would say that um
there are few moments all of these
actors have been doing amazing job but
Taylor and Timothy in in Nebraska uh
finding the way for uh for Lee to
communicate to Tamara and his hunting
ghosts of his past
or Tay Marin and Sally discussing the
their nature who they are on the
stairwell in Mrs Harbor House those
sequences were really like wow I'm a big
believer that Taylor in particular is
one of the best working actors of her
generation I think so like given the
fact that I like she's already done
wonderful things but she's going to go
on to do more and more what is it about
her as you know a lead in your film but
also as a collaborator and a partner
that you're really excited for even more
directors out there to get to experience
with her moving forward I think Taylor
is a a great a true filmmaker who
collaborates in a deep way and and is
not afraid of EX of going into places
and and bringing fragility out unearth
her own virginities that's something
valuable for for a process of filmmaking
in general whenever I see you talk about
your work and whenever whenever I see
anybody else talk about working with you
for that matter there's always like
there's always like a really passionate
calm to it so I kind of just Envision
you like breezing from scene to scene
with like no worries in the world so it
was making me wonder is there any
particular scene in bones and all that
had even you like circling that scene on
the shooting schedule and saying to
yourself like that might keep me up at
night that's the day I'm gonna have my
work cut out for me
no
to be honest no not at all not not that
I think about it no I think we we did a
theme uh which was driving in the night
and it was laborious technically and
then the sun went up and we had to stop
it which was quite frustrating because
they were doing a great job and then we
had to shoot it again like 10 days later
that must have been the most unnerving
moment but because of the time not
because of anything else it's all it's
also making me wonder in your I mean in
your entire body of work looking back is
there any particular scene that you
think you think of as the most difficult
that now makes you say like if I was
able to pull that off I can do anything
I did a scene in Challengers that is
it's a nine minute sequence that it took
us a week of routine
and I don't know probably 200 setups
so I did that so I think having done
that I think I can do anything now 200
setups is quite a bit so we've talked
we've talked a little bit about uh
Taylor but you basically have like a
full Ensemble of hugely talented
individuals who I think make their roles
uniquely their own so when you cast
these actors in these parts which role
would you say change the most from what
you read on the page to what someone did
when they brought it to life in front of
the camera I would say everyone because
you know like when you invite artists
like actors to perform you have to be
open to what they can bring to the to to
to the scene and and and and you want
the characters that are fleshed out on a
page to become real uh so you have to be
wanting and welcoming the change I hope
I word this question properly I spoke to
Taylor recently and she kind of like put
this idea in my mind because she was she
was telling me about what she thinks
make makes you such a standout director
and what she was explaining to me is how
like your passion for art goes beyond
filmmaking you love architecture you
love cooking and then some so it was
making me wonder is there any particular
unrelated passion or hobby that you have
that would surprise people out there to
know that actually influences your work
on film sets as well I love gardening
and I practice gardening and gardening
is about time and you have to be
incredibly patient and you can you have
to absolutely understand that you are
nothing in the front of Nature and if
you do not welcome that then if you
don't bend yourself to and bow to the
nature and to time you will fail no
matter how much money you can put into
it in order to build your garden
immediately it's not going to happen so
this is like a very beautiful lesson in
in patients and in in in Endeavor and in
and in conquering conquering uh someone
you love or you want the way in which
you can conquer a space out of green
in time I have the opposite of a green
thumb but I just recently sprouted like
the tiniest Bud out of like a pot of
nothing and I don't know the more
enthusiastic thing that can happen to
you right it's it really is something
special so I love your work in general
I'm an especially big horror fan who is
full-blown obsessed with uh Suspiria so
I have to ask before they kick me out of
here if you had the opportunity to uh to
make your own to adapt make a sequel
reboot you name it of any other iconic
horror movie out there which one would
you choose and why
oh my God that's an incredible question
that I didn't prepare myself to and oh
my God what should I do I want to do I
wanna I wanna say what I want to do I
don't know
um I think
I think it would be amazing to do
something about the mummy The Mummy is a
rock solid Choice yeah
can I can I ask before they make me
leave what is it that appeals to you
about the mummy and makes it something
that maybe is worth another revisit
nowadays it's a rotten body wrapped in
bandages we saw it inside it's
interesting as much as what is inside it
should be very scary and very very
terminal tiny it should be tiny
tiny how so
it should be a little movie but with a
lot of depths and very scary
so I'm universal
you know there is there is a there is a
Joe Dante mummy that never happened that
I feel so bad about because Joe is such
a master and I'm sure he would have made
something incredible
I would believe that would have turned
out to be incredible and and same for we
we manifest things on colliders so just
by us having this conversation we're
going to will it into existence I want
to see it happen but in the meantime
thank you for bones and all I loved it
and cannot wait to watch it over and
over and over again thank you you're so
kind